the people who really rule you
most of them are faceless bureaucrats
you've never heard of we have committed
ourselves one of the most common
misconceptions in our time is that we
are responsible more or less for the
whole world in perpetuity the founders
begin from a premise of non-interference
in the Affairs of other nations unless
that country poses a direct threat to
death the modern bureaucracies they
would say that it's impossible to stake
out a successful foreign policy that
sticks so closely to that of the
American Founders in a complex world
where America has all these
responsibilities and their view is you
either agree with them or you stay out
of their Lane foreign policy always has
to protect the nation and the people but
also American foreign policy it has to
protect our equal natural rights I
worked in both the George W bush and
Donald J Trump white houses both times
at the National Security Council these
people who are running the federal
bureaucracies have more power than the
people whose names you know who are
supposedly running American policy in
this course I'll be talking about the
principles and the practice of American
foreign policy the history key events
and the proper understanding of what the
American Founders intended and how we've
departed from that the story of American
foreign policy is a story of rising size
power influence along with Rising
ambition and I hope to give you the
tools to steer your government in
productive directions I'm Michael Anton
this is our course on American foreign
policy
let's begin
in all these regions
we too have a very big state
[Music]